what's going on guys welcome to
the sixth i think bitcoin trading video
in this video we're actually going to
back test
uh a very simple trading strategy i'm
not gonna give you guys you know an epic
trading strategy or anything by all
means
uh but actually the rsi plays out pretty
well in theory so it's actually pretty
neat
and not many people are using training
strategies around this time so there's a
lot of trading
formulas and technical analysis
indicators that are actually working
very well with bitcoin right now just
simply because
not many people are using them and once
a lot of people start using them
you'll find that the market's volatility
will decrease and the
actual results of using the indicators
will also decrease
but for now uh there's actually a lot of
indicators that work
very well with this market so now that
we've
uh you know seen the data we're not
actually you know gonna look at it
anymore so i'm going to make another
function
and i'm going to get rid of testing data
for now and just i'm just come down here
and add another function basically and
this one we're going to call
back testing so now we're going to make
a function
that back tests and tells us the results
of our training strategy
against the actual historical data so we
can know
um how well our trading strategy would
have played out in the past
and we can kind of make it you know
educated ish guess
how well it'll play out in the future
generally you'll want to compare it to
similar market conditions so
uh really you'd only want to back test
this against maybe the last month
or maybe two months but anything but
back
further won't necessarily be the most
accurate it could be
depending on what kind of strategy
you're using if you're using like
machine learning or something like that
to
figure out the best trading strategy
then you would want to back test it
across
all data because you're really back
testing your machine learning capability
not a single formula because machine
learning is going to make a dynamic
formula
so anyway let's go ahead and backtest so
we're going to say try and accept
just like usual uh exception
e print uh failed main
back uh test try
and then uh string e whatever that
failure was
now we're gonna want to say um and
actually shoot we
might as well just take all of this
because
we really need all that data populated
anyways
so under testing data take everything in
that first
you know from the beginning of that
function all the way down to the
exception
and literally paste and that
should be good we'll just get rid of
this try here
cool and i guess we'll get rid of this
except
anyway so now we're all set there and
that's going to populate our data
now we want to do is come down here and
it kind of makes sense to smooth out
the data um so there's a couple ways
that you can actually smooth out the
data and you can do this in real
time but the data is no doubt very
volatile data so sometimes it might make
sense to smooth it out so
i'm going to also show you guys how we
can go about smoothing out
uh that data so let me drag over a
centex tab again since that's where
we're going to get the
stuff um just as a side note we do have
the uh sentiment for bitcoin right now
it's pretty weak but it is going up
let's i just want to refresh see what
we're looking at now
um so it is going up a little bit so
hopefully we'll
maybe see some more increase in a little
bit right now it's kind of lagging down
um anyway so then go to centex.com
under the about tab um you're going to
want to click on
the tutorials scroll down to the
programming stock
click on that go back to that sample
code that we were looking at before
and this time we're going to steal the
exponential moving average function so
copy that come over to our script and
just paste that function in
so we're going to use that in a second
so now we'll come down here to the
testing data make sure you're not
programming in or not testing data i'm
sorry make sure you're not programming
and testing data
make sure you're programming and back
testing it's going to be really easy to
accidentally code in the wrong function
because it looks very similar
so come down here under the accept
and what you're going to want to do is
say email
equals exp moving
average and we want to apply this to btc
price array and let's give it a 50
moving average because we have a lot of
data
so we might as well give it a law of uh
or a large exponential moving average
now we're going to define the rsi
so we're going to say rsi line equals
the
rsi function and we're going to say
ema prices and then n
equals some large number let's use 1500.
now uh we're gonna run
through our data and how far back is
still
in effect so that's good so now we
actually want to do is we want to run
through everything so we're going to
make a counter
so we're going to do uh sorry x equals 0
and then we're going to say stance
equals
none because we're basically gonna back
test this
and act like as if we had traded so
we're gonna say
stance is none because we don't have one
going in then we're gonna say
last bought four currently we haven't
bought anything so we'll just leave that
at zero
and then total profit starts at zero
because
well we've made no profit now the next
thing that we want to do
is we're going to say um
we want to know kind of like how much
um time we've actually traded right
uh so it just kind of makes it easy to
know like how much profit do we make in
x time so we're gonna say print
starting time and this is going to be
kind of a long operation but it's going
to be the string version of
datetime.datetime.fromtimestamp
uh then we float
btc date r
and date array we want the zero with
data array
uh since we use that how far back kind
of thing going on there right
so data a and then um
outside of you know two parentheses
we've got some more typing to do so
dot s-t-r-f-t-i-m-e
and then we denote um what kind of time
stamp we wanted to give us so
we're just gonna say percent y perc dash
percent lower case m dash percent lower
case d
space percent capital h colon capital
m oops capital percent m colon and then
percent
uh capital s and i said uh
m percent do percent m so make sure it
looks just like mine
do as i do not as i say
next uh that should print out the
timestamp now what we're going to do is
wow
x is less than the length of rsi line so
however long
rsi line actually is we're gonna say
you know you can either have two stances
you can have
um you can have either
you know some bitcoin you could be
holding something or not
um so if stance is
uh none so let's say you didn't have a
stance
uh and then what would we be looking for
well we're looking for a certain buy
point on the rsi
so i'm going to say if rsi line
x is actually less than if it's less
than
40 we're going to say hey that's
oversold
let's buy so we're going to say stance
equals holding because we bought
uh also we want to know uh what we're
buying for
so print uh buying btc at
and then we want to know how much do we
pay for this btc so we're gonna say btc
uh price array
x so that's how much we bought it for
now we're gonna say last
bought for equals
uh btc price ray
x so that's going to save to this last
bot 4 variable
how much we paid for it and that's
it next we're going to want to come down
here and if stance
isn't none we'll call the elif statement
lf stance equals uh
holding what do we want to do you could
probably just say
elif but whatever um if
rsi line x is
greater than 60 we're going to say hey
that's overbought we need to sell
stance equals
none then we actually need to go ahead
and sell so let's say
print uh
selling btc at
btc btc
price array x whatever that is
then we're going to go ahead and
calculate fees so
since we're using um btc
exchange the fees are 0.2 percent
each way so point four percent total if
you were on mount gox the percent
or the fee is 0.6 percent
so 1.2 percent for a whole transaction
now keep in mind however mount gox
is highly volatile the volatility of
mount guys is just massive
uh in theory mount gox should have three
times the volatility of btce because
they have three times
the uh fee that's not the case mount gox
is more like
30 times the volatility so it could make
more sense to trade on mount gox
just going to throw that out there um so
keep that in mind but anyway
here the fees are 0.2 both ways but
we're going to say
fees equals you're going to pay 0.00
times that's you know 0.2 times
what was the um basically you're paying
two percent on the
buy and the sell so you just add them
together to get the exact fee that you
would have paid
so btc price array x wherever we are
plus last bought oops this is camelcase
last bought four so we add those
together and that will give us
whatever the fee was and then we're
going to go ahead and say print
uh fee for this was
and fees and then we're gonna say print
uh profit
on this trade colon
and that profit is going to be btc price
ra x uh minus
last bought four minus
uh whatever the fees were so what did
we finally sell it at minus how much did
we pay
minus the fees so that'll give us a
negative if if we lost money it'll give
us a positive if we made money
next we're going to do total profit
plus equals and we really just want to
plus equals
this so i'm just going to highlight it
copy it
and paste it right in here so that will
be
you know how much did we actually make
or lose once all of that is done
outside of the l if while in this while
loop
we're going to do x plus equals one and
that's it
now we're going to actually back test
this trading strategy so now we just
need to actually call
the function back test and actually do
a back test so paste that in save
and we'll go ahead and run this so hit
run we have an invalid
syntax right here forgot the comma
save and run okay so let's drag this
over
um so we went back
oh you know what we ought to do is
we have profit let's see total profit on
this trade so then we actually want to
go ahead
and outside of the entire thing so
outside of the while loop
uh we want to print a
total profit of and then we want to have
a total profit
okay and again this time i see i think
we only went back like 30k
or something oh no we went back 50k
uh anyway let me close this and let's
rerun it um let me drag this over
uh i was printing out as i did it okay
so the starting time
was last night basically this looks like
it was let me think
about a
eight hours ago or so for me so from all
the trades we bought at 806 we sold at
8.25
then we uh
fee was three we made 15. then we bought
it 851 we sold 864 paid our fee
made some profit uh then we
bought it 866 sold at 8 74
paid our fee profit we bought it 864
we never finished the trade and so here
we are
so we made 30 on our 800-ish dollar
investment uh so
really that comes to basically 3.7
percent
overnight uh it's actually not not that
bad and you did better than the market
well i suppose if you had bought held at
800 you would be
more so at um
well at least right now you'd be at 850
or so so you might have actually made
more money if you had bought and held
but i don't think it's too fair to
compare to the buy and hold strategy
simply because buy and hold is a lot
riskier than buying and holding in the
stock market
so if you really wanted to compare and
like be like is this worth my time and
energy compare it to like
the profit from buying and holding in
the stock market and that's a
more fair comparison and 3.75 overnight
it's pretty good for a fairly
low risk trading strategy i would say
this is pretty low risk
uh you're not going to lose like a
thousand dollars instantly by mistake as
soon as it becomes oversold
uh you're good to go so uh not too much
to worry about there
uh so anyway now let's let's go ahead
and link lengthen this out and like
let's say we trade not fifty thousand
let's do five hundred
000 so let's save that run that
hopefully i can drag it over quick
enough
get some trade action going on
here we go so did we make money we made
81
with this trading strategy so you know
10 percent profit probably from starting
point about
um actually we actually started trading
on the fifth so
four days ago for me and what's neat
about this trading strategy
and why uh you would much rather do this
than buy and hold bitcoin
is as you can see if in this trading
strategy if you were comparing this to
the buy and hold strategy
it started at 973 bitcoin did
and it ends 100 over 100 cheaper at 8.64
yet including fees and everything you
made 81
so you profited even though the price of
bitcoin
went down so you made money while
bitcoin was dropping
and so i would say that's a pretty nice
strategy
so anyways uh that's the basics of back
testing a simple
structure a simple trading strategy
with bitcoin now there's obviously a lot
of things you can do you can adjust a
lot of variables
here um and obviously you could go back
even further we've got like
uh this is 500 000. we can go back 5
million lines
and see how much money we made um but
anyway
i'll let you guys kind of play with it
you can decide what you really want to
do
so anyways i hope you guys enjoyed uh
hopefully you learned something new
hopefully you're enjoying your time with
uh
playing with bitcoin uh if i helped you
out enough i do have a donation link
with bitcoin
in the description so check that out if
you liked what i was doing here for you
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions
until next time